not only the seven of nine remain one of
fans most beloved Star Trek heroes of
the past her story has continued beyond
Voyager to the franchise's 21st century
series out at a character named after a
couple of numbers become so beloved the
special feature braving the unknown on
Star Trek Voyager season for home
release reveals where the idea for seven
of nine came from Brannon Braga producer
and writer on Voyager says the notion of
a Borg character joining the crew came
to him while watching an ad for the
season 3 episode unity in the episode
Commander Chakotay finds a planet a Borg
who had been disconnected from the
collective unfortunately conflict rages
on the planets as rivals between
different species reemerge once ties to
the Borg have been severed an export
human named Riley wants voyagers help to
create a new collective on the planet in
order to restore harmony in the meantime
Riley and other exports temporarily
connect chucko to their collective in
order to heal life-threatening wounds
and eventually to use that connection to
force voyagers first officer to help
them chuckle taste experience in unity
becomes crucial in voyagers early
dealings with seven of nine Braga said
after watching the promo for unity he
called Voyager rider Jovanovski and Show
co-creator Rick Berman
to make sure having an export character
joined the show's regular cast wasn't a
stupid idea the consensus was that it
was just the opposite when seven of nine
first comes aboard Voyager she isn't
there as a friend she first appears in
scorpion part two the show's season four
premiere
upon entering an area of space dominated
by the Borg the crew of Voyager
discovers that the board can bitten off
more than they can chew erase a vicious
extra dimensional aliens known only as
species 8472 is waging war on the Borg
and winning
Captain Janeway sizes up the situation
it decides to use it to her advantage
after the ship's doctor devises a
technology that can defeat species 8472
Janeway offers it to the Borg in
exchange for safe passage through their
space the Borg then assigned seven of
nine a human assimilated when she was a
child to act as a liaison to voyagers
crew one species 8472 is defeated seven
of nine predictably turns on the crew of
Voyager she tells them their agreement
is over and the Borg will assimilate the
ship and her crew expecting the betrayal
Janeway signals for her secret plan to
be put in motion now
were on the ship the doctor puts a neuro
transfer sir is able to use to connect
with seven and distract her while
lieutenant Torres cuts sevens connection
to the collective making reoccurring
appearances on Star Trek Picard seven of
nine is one of the only Voyager regular
characters to show up in the franchise
after the show's finale it's ironic
considering that Brandon Braga planned
for her to be one of the only regular
characters to not even survive Voyager
speaking to Trek core in 2013 Bragg
appealed it a question about some fans
feeling Voyager had deep bang the Borg
his villains after talking about the
Borg for a bit he revealed his own ideas
for sevens fate I think seven of nine
should have bit the dust I think there
had to be a real sacrifice for this crew
getting home a real blood sacrifice
seven of nine was for me designed to be
a character that was going to die
tragically I planned that he went on to
describe how he planned for that death
to take place mentioning human error one
of the final seasons later episodes
seven uses the holodeck to explore her
human side including a potential romance
with Chuck otay as emotions begin to
emerge the Doctor discovers there's a
Borg failsafe device within her if she
becomes too human the implant will kill
her Braga said it was that moment in my
mind that would set up the finale where
she realized she can't live here can't
live there for better or worse progress
concept got the thumbs down and seven
continued her quest to become more human
while they start off as uneasy allies
the relationship between Captain Janeway
and seven of nine eventually grows into
something not unlike that between a
mother and daughter behind the scenes
however it seems clear that Kate Mulgrew
and Jeri Ryan were not the best of
friends when asked about her
relationship with Ryan at the 2014 Star
Trek Vegas con Mulgrew was diplomatic
saying quote we did not have a deep
friendship
Mulgrew implied that she had initially
resented ryan's casting saying it was
very clear to anyone with eyes in their
head that Jeri Ryan's beauty and sexual
appeal were an important part of the
numbers I had thought damn we were going
to forego all this with a female captain
but the demographics proved the audience
wanted more sex and they got it in that
beautiful talented woman on a 2013
episode of the girl on guy podcast ryan
opened up about how ugly things got she
didn't specifically named Mulgrew who is
the actor in question but her hints made
it seem impossible for them to be anyone
else
she gave examples of the actor refusing
to let makeup and wardrobe crew work
with Ryan before close-ups and in some
cases saying their lines to Ryan
off-camera while examining their
fingernails or thumbing through a book
without even making eye contact when
asked what her favorite episodes of
Voyager were Jeri Ryan has shared her
fond memories of episodes that saw seven
exploring her humanity in particular she
often cites season fives someone to
watch over me in the episode seven and
Torres almost come to blows when the
latter discovers that seven has been
observing and making notes on her and
Tom Paris as part of a study on other
species mating rituals when the doctor
suggests seven should try dating on her
own the holographic position becomes the
reformed boards dating mentor among
other things he subjects seven to a
presentation reminiscent of a high
school teacher sex education lecture
brings her to the holodeck to try her
hand at wooing holographic characters
teaches her to dance and breaks into a
sweet duet two of you are my sunshine
over the course of the episode the
doctor realizes he's developing his own
feelings for seven he's just about ready
to open up about them when she tells him
she will no longer need to be mentored
because after reviewing all the men on
board
none are suitable as potential mates the
doctor thanks seven and keeps his
longing to himself
chucko to actor Robert Beltran was known
for being honest about his opinions when
he wasn't happy about something
even while Voyager was still on the air
and one of the things he wasn't happy
about was how he felt Chuck otay and
other characters were shortchanged once
seven of nine came aboard speaking to
Star Trek comm in 2012
Beltran said when the seven of nine
character made her entrance the focus
changed that was fine with me but I
think writers have an obligation to fill
out all the characters if they're
regular characters on a series I think
several of the characters were
diminished
chucko Tay and taboc and Kim and Neelix
he went on to say he felt seven was
easier to write because she wasn't fully
human Brian told the girl on guy podcast
she thought so much focus was put on
seven because simply put she was new she
also said she was aware of some of the
other cast resentment and understood
them though the understanding apparently
didn't make things easier looking back
on the experience she said when the new
kid comes in and suddenly it's all about
them that was tough it really made it an
unpleasant work experience 7 of 9 isn't
the only X Borg to join Voyager on its
quest back to earth in season 6
elective the crew encounters a board
cube whose only survivors are children
at the end of the episode for the
children come aboard Voyager where the
doctor uses the same techniques he used
on seven to remove most of the
children's Borg implants the oldest of
the four is each M a member of a race
called Brunelli who becomes a recurring
character on Voyager we eventually
learned that each EPS assimilation into
the Borg was somewhat unique in the
episode child's play each hub discovers
he was genetically engineered by his
parents with a deadly virus meant to
eradicate the Borg his parents willingly
put him on a ship and steered him toward
the Borg in hopes they would assimilate
him and subsequently be destroyed eat
chips not baked he's a weapon
unfortunately each M is brutally taken
away from 7:00 in the season one episode
of Star Trek Picard starred US city Rag
in a flashback we learned each F has
been captured and then his body's being
harvested for its cybernetic parts 7
interrupts the procedure BD cheb is
already dying and in excruciating pain
he begged seven to kill him and she
ultimately does one of the most
well-loved stories of any Star Trek show
is the original series episode mirror
mirror in which the dark parallel
universe is revealed the tyrannical
Terran Empire replaces the Federation
and evil counterparts of the
enterprise's crew replaced the ones with
which were more familiar subsequent
series like Deep Space nine enterprise
and discovery return to the mirror
universe though Voyager never got a
chance
that's something comic book publisher ID
w's 2019 one-shot story Star Trek
Voyager mirrors and smoke aims to
correct in the mirror universe Janeway
is the pirate queen of the Delta
Quadrant and is perfectly content to
stay far from Earth where she and her
crew can plunder without anyone to
interfere in this universe seven of nine
previously known as Annika Hansen was
never assimilated by the Borg but her
parents were when Voyager rescues her
from Neelix and casts Annika discovers
the Terrans know nothing about the Borg
ironically while Annika isn't a Borg in
this universe she still betrays Voyager
shortly after she's rescued she plots
with the doctor to take over the ship
and kill anyone who doesn't cooperate
their plans are foiled and interesting
Leon ACCA's motivations for turning
against them are never revealed go
toward the end of the comics she refers
to her captors as the humans suggesting
she may be more than she appears
one of the most anticipated appearances
of Star Trek Picard's first season was
the return of seven of nine she saves
Picard and his crew at the end of
absolute candor and takes center stage
in the following episode stardust city
rag we learned that for years seven has
been part of a group of vigilantes
called the Fenris Rangers trying to
bring justice to the galaxy in the wake
of the Romulan supernova as much of a
success as sevens return is proven to be
Gerry Ryan never thought it would happen
on the Picard after-show programme ready
room ryan told host Wil Wheaton that
when the idea was first pitched to her
two years before production she thought
it was a joke because this has been a
two-year process since I first since it
was first broached yeah to me and I
didn't think it was ever going to really
actually come to fruition apparently it
wasn't until the 2018 creative arts
Emmys when Ryan was shocked to discover
her return to the role was actually a
possibility while she waited backstage
Picard co-creator Alex Kurtzman told her
there was a lot of discussion about her
in the series writers room it's like
what really okay I guess it's actually
happening at first it may seem strange
for seven of nine to show up in Star
Trek Picard after all the character
wasn't around for Star Trek The Next
Generation and we've never seen the two
characters meet before Picard however if
you stop to think about it seven may
have more in common with Picard than
anyone he served with aboard the
enterprise in the two-part TNG episode
best of both worlds Picard is
assimilated by the Borg and turned into
Locutus the collective uses his memories
and knowledge to kill Picard Starfleet
comrades he's eventually saved by his
crew but the experience leaves deep
scars while seven was assimilated when
she was a young girl and spent a much
longer time with the collective than
Picard they shared this terrible bond
with one another this never comes
through more clearly than in an exchange
toward the end of stardust city rag 7s
Picard if he thinks he regained his
humanity once he was cut off from the
Borg he says he did but seven is
skeptical and gets Picard to admit that
there's still a little bit of humanity
he hasn't been able to get back from the
war
that we're both working on it
[Music]
every ten day of my life check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
you